[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i have a question for all of you
what is your favorite movie if i say the
name of a movie clap really lolly if you
like the movie and don't clap if you
don't like the movie
first i have superman
[Applause]
frankenweenie
[Applause]
pie to the caribbean
wars
avengers age of ultron
and finally harry potter
one of the things that all these movies
have in common is that they all have or
include special effects why am i
interested in special effects i've
always wondered how movies were made for
example in star wars episodes 4x when
attacking the death star how did they do
that and compared to the caribbean how
did they do davy jones face
i decided to find out for myself
what are special effects they create
everything imaginary in movies or tv
shows and its purpose is to make
something imaginary look real let me
talk a bit about the history effects
george melies a trip to the moon made in
the year 1902 was the first movie to use
miniature models here's a picture of the
miniature model of the moon from his
movie
modern movies still use this kind of
miniature technique today like in the
movie lore of the rings on the right you
can see a picture of the argonauth from
the movie what appears to be gigantic
you see on the left in real life while
it's only as big as a human there are
two types of special effects
mechanical effects or practical effects
and digital effects or visual effects
chemical effects have been used since
the beginning of film like george
milie's a trip to the moon with the use
of miniature models they create wounds
blood splatter dirt grime real makeup
and even more digital effects use
computers like putting in the miniature
organized in the movie lord of the rings
they create digital creatures animation
explosions digital makeup and even more
than that here's a video of my sci-fi
effects i will explain to you how i did
them as the videos playing i used the
effectio and the effects gear wraps to
create this
[Music]
this one i took a picture of a space
background then i put the shift set for
the shifts i positioned the light
direction and the rotation this took me
about 35 minutes
for this one i want a computer generate
background so i did that i changed the
light direction and rotation of the
ships and this took me about 45 minutes
and for this one i took a picture
outside then i put the monster in the
challenge here was that i had to
position the light direction of the
effects monster to the real light
direction of the sun
this took me about 45 minutes as well
here's some more sci-fi effects uh this
one's called dragon the world i use the
creature effects app to create this the
dragon is a digital effect and
everything else is mechanical the trees
in the background were moved using a
stick and timing was essential to make
the scene more realistic
here's my stars effect called the
lightsaber i use the saber movie effects
app to create this
a challenge here was that i had to
position the individual lightsaber blade
in every single frame in this little
film this took me about an hour and 15
minutes
oh no
i sliced it
here's my blaster effects and this one
just like the last one with the
lightsaber i had to position the
individual blaster shot in every single
frame this took me about 15 minutes the
blaster shot is the only digital effect
here and the coolest mechanical effect
is the box that's really on fire i also
added a stormtrooper blasted shot sound
here's my star trek effect called nine
enterprise i used the action movie
effects app to create this in case
you're wondering where i got the cloud
background i filmed this on the plane to
get the altitude effect
here's my actual effects called the
crusher the car and foot are both
digital and everything else is
mechanical
here's my digital makeup i use the
course cam out to do this
starting on the left we have a wolfman
frankenstein water creature and even a
name now let me talk a little bit about
effects and roots horror increases your
heartbeat makes you feel more alive
sci-fi does the same thing to me but i
like sci-fi way more than hard comedies
and laughter actually de-stress you and
help your immune system for my
presentation i'm any comedy animation
that i'm not going to show you just yet
i'm going to show it to you at the end
like a little bonus
what can kids do when they have their
hands special effects of course they can
have fun but it's not just play they
could be practicing for future jobs
jobs in the effects industry can include
animator digital artist creature modeler
digital compositor and even a technical
director what about the future of
special effects i think actors will
still remain in the movie business
because it would be kind of weird if
everything was effects including the
actors by then you will be able to make
three-dimensional movies in your own
home and there will be no mechanical
effects used whatsoever
speaking of non-mechanical effects there
is a car called the blackbird which can
become any car possible sadly you cannot
see this cool trick with the human eye
as it only works if seen using a special
computer here's a picture of the
blackbird as you can see it is basically
just an esco skeleton of the car that
can actually change its length and
height to replicate any car possible
little black thing that you can see on
the top of the car is actually a 360
degree view camera which it uses to see
everything around it and create the
reflection on the car's metal this is a
picture of a normal jaguar isn't it
or maybe not
let's enlarge this photo
now cut out the middle part
as you can see this is actually the
blackbird here is a picture of the
blackberry becoming many cars at one
time as you can see there's no need for
real cars and movies tv shows or
advertisements anymore
finally this is the comedy animation i
promised you it's called
i farted
[Music]
i farted
i farted also
thank you
[Applause]